perfect
good um
so the intersection of blockchain and
gaming
um
there we go
okay yeah there's a little bit of light
not too much good good okay so um
so who am i uh i'm a traditional game
designer um i've done you know done some
consulting on casual but a lot of my
experience is kind of core games across
pc console mobile um and then more
recently my group has been uh diving
into things with roblox uh probably the
two biggest of which are the little
nausea concert and the 21 uh in 2020 and
the the um
21 pilots concert in 2021
um now
um
we're the kind of primary um high-res
concert provider for roblox we're going
to be continuing to do things with them
and we're using that as a jumping off
point to find our own space and pacing
in virtual events as everybody begins to
talk about the metaverse
i will say that i'm
not going to intentionally talk about
the metaverse here um it's it's uh it's
a thing that i could wax poetic on for
hours um it's um
sadly ironic because we're still so far
from it um but there's a lot of ground
to get to it and i really want to talk
more about the ground going towards it
rather than the
uh ill-defined inspiration that comes
out of um
uh film and and books that uh that we
will eventually get to if we're lucky
so
um i want to start first with this um
technology is not a religion um
bitcoin or otherwise
we are in a space now where quite a
number of people are treating
um
it as it
treating bitcoin and cryptocurrency and
nfts as a religion but i think that we
can all come from their perspective that
there's a lot of really interesting
technology there
and we need to put it into perspective
i
i
come from kind of a training
that i can remember sitting down with
with my former boss mentor john carmack
and he was always very clear about the
notion that
when we were building
we were platform and device agnostic
that we were building first and foremost
for
whatever
devices were in front of us and we're
optimizing for those
that we would use a mixture of what was
local on device and what could support
that online
and the important thing was to take what
was there
you know whether we were working at that
point for pc for console for mobile uh
experimenting with bits of vr uh you
know this was effectively a little bit
more than 10 years ago but the notion
that these were all computing devices
and the most important thing was to make
them sing
it was not to
put one above the other but to know that
these were just different user
interfaces for getting at computing
so with that in mind
um
i'm gonna
balance this with with you know some
text heavy bits i'm not gonna read those
out um and and some graphics but
um i i want to just have us think about
um
some of the key aspects of things that
are game technology um
consoles to pc uh that start to then get
balanced out with this thread of online
from arpanet to bitnet to the internet
optical storage change things
drastically
the gpu is kind of the other big thing
but then there's been this interesting
mixture of mobile and cloud
that took a while to sort out where they
fit and blockchain
in that is something that is still
trying to find its pacing
specifically within
this overall channel of game technology
so
this isn't really here to dive into the
bits but to just give you kind of a top
line perspective there have been
this interesting range of
pc and console and handheld technology
flowing back and forth
over a fairly long period but what does
that really mean
going to revenue
and i i want to try to give a few
different perspectives on this but
things started off really with arcade
games then console comes in then
handheld then
pc
um
and mobile and then vr and these things
are all moving and growing at different
paces uh this sense that we go from kind
of one computing paradigm to another and
that we
that most of these have been device
um
at least at
uh to our current understanding um where
other things play a supporting role
because of the the primacy of basically
running
um in 3d where possible on the device
um so
just going back here for a second
uh i just want to note that um this kind
of wraps up in the
um
roughly 2018-2019 period
and what's interesting there if you look
at the end of it is that this was
starting to get up i think it crests at
about 139 billion
um for the the total size of this gaming
market
and then
in
2020 and 2021 it grows uh and it grows
drastically under the pandemic um
basically
everybody goes online everybody buys
devices that's that's what's led to our
semiconductor and supply chain shortage
in in a large part is this notion that
everyone's at home everyone's on zoom
calls uh everyone is buying devices
everyone is trying to deal with the
pandemic in different ways but using
similar
tools and processes and computing for it
and so we go to 159 billion and 180
billion with a massive amount of growth
that
is starting to even out but is not
stopping it's just slowing its
acceleration a little bit
so
uh monetization
again just kind of for this overall
perspective from arcades to consoles to
uh to personal computers
bulletin boards
pc shareware
pc mmos console online mobile free to
play
you'll see this shortly in terms of
specific timeline but pc console online
games uh as a service actually coming
into play coherently in the last decade
and then
this experiment with blockchain
just in the last um you know really
year to kind of year and a half that
we're trying to make sense of
and a little bit before that
the
rise and then and then crash of icos and
now the the bubble of nfts
um
so
what that has meant
is that
we have this timeline where
you can see arcades grow and peak
and trail off and basically die for the
most part during the pandemic um
console has
had its its crash in the 80s and came
back
from you know effectively and
simplifying it from atari to nintendo
and then we've had pc
start in the 80s and be fairly
consistent
but handheld grow
and then technically really kind of fold
into into console
and mo and then the rise of mobile as we
as we get into the
uh effectively the um
the odds and then the teams uh and then
mobile take off to where it's become the
largest part of game monetization um
really effectively by kind of subsuming
uh
the beginnings of what were first in pc
of of web gaming
and then there's this tiny sliver of vr
and effectively it's a thing that's
always changing because there's this
mixture of
what are the delivery mechanisms and
those change over time as we shift our
computing paradigms from one to the next
and also as we widen the market we bring
more people in
so um
with these i'm just going to kind of
show you uh show all of you a handful of
of different things for comparison um
i'll be frank i'm
going to um
uh bypass pc uh even though we're on
that um and it's frankly near and dear
to my heart it's where i started in this
industry um
but um
the pc has been kind of a steady
lifeline because it is frankly the most
open
um the pc
is a consistent thing and then all these
others have kind of moved around
um but you know there have been many
notions of the death knell of the of pc
computing and that's not going away
anytime soon so the pc has been
steady
it has grown but it's kind of
leveled
and it's interesting then for seeing
these other ones come around it so
this is showing seven or i should say
from
gen two to gen seven we're now in gen
nine of console but console has seen
this steady um
really mathematical um
linear non-exponential curve of
slow
kind of plotting but very consistent
growth as the console market gets a
little bit bigger a little bit faster
each time
so
mobile
the interesting thing about mobile here
is that
and and qualcomm is very good about
about
explaining this
mobile is a really good illustration of
the
the hardware computing industry moving
in 30-year cycles
um
qualcomm and nvidia talk about this but
really the semiconductor folks as a
whole
they understand that they are building
devices across generally speaking
30-year cycles
and what that means is that
mobile
is really reaching a peak
in you know 2022
that effectively goes back to about 1992
and
that first 15 years
of mobile was just kind of getting it
set up and and really it's been the last
um
you know
the last uh let's say 15 years of
smartphones and effectively if you think
about it about five years or so feature
phones before that
but that's why when we look at mobile
and it looks like it has
this
you know the end of a hockey stick it's
because the full hockey stick is there
the first 15 years is growing to where
we can get to the to that tip of the
hockey stick um and so you look at at
the iphone curve um
and you see
it you know in that period from
2007 to 2012
and it starts to grow quickly and you
get from
you know from effectively 1 million
to
10 you know like
10 to 20 to 40 to 75 to 125. it's this
very quick growth and that's because
it's built on the backs of 15 years
of growth before that
and
if you go from just iphone
then over to android and you stick
iphone into android
and you look at the overall
smartphone mobile space
um that it's even more pronounced
because of the additional volume of
android and so
mobile computing basically took off
in that 15 years
figuring out what it needed to do
and then growing exponentially at the
end of that but oftentimes
when people are talking about mobile
and you know i was at it software in
that 2000
um you know that
2010
2012 period where
mobile went from okay we kind of have
something interesting like i you know
bought my first
um
ipod touch going
it's a computer i need to mess around
with this and then going oh everyone's
getting this
at first it's just a handful of us going
this isn't a thing i need to figure out
how to play with and make sure i
understand what it's doing and gradually
learn how to make it sing
and then you go you know effective
effectively you know you have this thing
that started
in 1990
and
didn't have much of an impact and i can
remember my father who was
traveling for research getting a
satellite phone
and going oh you know in in the 90s and
going what the hell is this thing going
from that to
um you know
having a um you know a motorola
feature phone and bypassing the rim
space but
you know i can remember at ea
every producer had
um a
had a blackberry they were all glued to
it but it was just the producers you
know effectively the you know quote
unquote business side folks and then
going
oh this thing with a screen comes out i
can use that and then going from that to
everyone has them and then not just
everyone has them but
everyone globally has them and it
becomes um
it it grows to the point
where now
no one has their phone far from them
you know everyone has their phone in
their pockets in their hands um on their
desks as i do right now
everyone has
it and it becomes your second brain
and so computing goes through this in
these 30-year cycles
the internet right now
is mirroring
mobile in that they both started in
1990.
neither one of them is permanent
the internet will probably eventually
get replaced
and just as
arpanet and bitnetwork before the
internet
if we can get to a metaverse thing down
the road
we're at peak internet we are also at
peak mobile um we're seeing experiments
into the next um phase of both of those
things uh with ar glasses and with
metaverse and they're still very early
and there's still probably about
10 to 15 to 20 years away but they need
to be
because the early folks are the ones who
were you know in
phones in the 90s
and then
even in the early teens before the
smartphone and the feature phone days
and that's kind of where we are right
now with blockchain um
i'm i'm aware of when it started but
for the impact on folks
gaming has been around
effectively
and depending on how you went accounted
since the 60s to the 70s uh vr actually
even predates that um with sensorama
back in in the 50s but blockchain is
still
trying to figure out its impact as it's
as it is in relation to gaming so with
that
we're going to touch on cloud for a
second
because cloud um is something that goes
back to
uh back to the odds um
yeah and um effectively aws in
2003
and uh azure in 2009 and others coming
off of that um
amazon is frankly the big dog in the
space um
i can remember a point where amazon was
you know 80 of the market now it's 33
there's
more diversity and there's more space
and this is just tracking here a few of
amazon to azure to gcloud to ibm cloud
alibaba cloud salesforce but you know
you can you can map out just the chinese
cloud because it's its own thing and
it's largely behind the great firewall
of china
this is interesting because you can you
can basically see that microsoft for the
most part started to make money
uh revenue off of cloud
in you know this period of roughly 2013
to 2015
um
tracking here from the beginning of 2015
but then it starts to take off really
steadily 2016 2017-2018
and and now it's become a major part of
of their revenue um
going from microsoft
to um to amazon with the one on the
right here
and this is tracking a wider range
again
this is tracking
um
if you look at 2009 that's when azure
started and that's when when azure
started is when amazon really started to
make money in cloud
but you look at that that range and the
period from again
up to about
2013
is still very small
um and it's effectively the period from
then around 2013 2014 up to now where
it's it's started to grow ex you know um
you know almo almost exponentially the
the impact is is huge uh where it was
not before
um and then the other thing i want to
highlight is is that especially in the
enterprise space
um
cloud is is uh is basically taking over
um that
and and what this is tracking is the
amount of overall software to you know
to the amount of cloud where to be fair
this is going up to 2032
but what this is saying is that there's
an expectation that around about
2024 2025
that half the software globally will be
running on cloud that there's this
assumption
um you know whether it happens or not
that
more and more software is
is growing i i actually believe that a
good amount will stay on device
but that there's going to be this
mixture of cloud and edge and blockchain
and
we're still finding the balance and
we're still finding the hybridization
because in my mind
nothing
absolutely nothing ever replaces a
certain amount of
code execution on the device side
but
we're learning to support
and right now
we're mostly learning from cloud because
cloud has this history going back to aws
in 2003
and so this is you know
we're now gonna kind of transition into
blockchain but i i wanted folks to
understand
that
looking at this especially as it comes
into games but in a lot of other fields
as well
um the interesting thing is going
how did mobile impact how did cloud
impact what lessons do you take from
each
because mobile and cloud have both
drastically affected games
so now we're going to dump uh heavily
into games in blockchain but i wanted
that that grounding for everybody and i
hope that was helpful
um so
this was a survey that came out
just a few weeks ago
this was a survey
that i believe was taken
um
in the period of december to january of
this year um and
this is um
setting up for the game developers
conference which happens every march um
in san francisco and this is asking
um
game developers who are connected into
gdc and the igda um the game developers
conference and the international game
developers association what is your
interest in cryptocurrency as a pa as a
payment tool
most are not interested
what is your studio's interest in nfts
most are not interested
that can change but
um i wanted to highlight that because
the biggest thing that's impacting that
is the current state of the nft bubble
and
the amount of
negative press
because of how people are going into it
and because of what is being announced
and it's not
a fundamental
view of the technology it's where are we
right now
what's going on right now and how is
that impacting people and when they're
reading industry news what are they
looking at and how is that shaping their
perspective
um and and frankly when they're reading
mainstream news and they're hearing
about things how is that affecting what
they're what they're going to develop on
um and and the reason is because
the reaction to
this very loose range of web 3 nft
blockchain cryptocurrency that are
mashed together and they're different
things
but the reaction to that as a whole
is fundamentally different
than the reaction to mobile and
fundamentally different to the reaction
to cloud
because
with mobile
some people immediately loved it
and
a lot of other folks were like i don't
quite know what that is but the
monetization for mobile happened slower
than people believe i remember really
well and it took four to five years
um the interesting thing about that
with mobile is that
where it changed is everyone got
smartphones
and when everyone got smartphones
no one really hated mobile
some people were like i wanna i wanna
develop on it i don't wanna develop on
it but no one said
i don't want it to exist because
everyone's like well i've got a
smartphone
and all the game developers got
smartphones faster than just about
anyone else other than other
technology folks everyone in technology
adopted first
and so
that's the thing to think about is
nobody
hated on mobile because everyone had one
no one hated on cloud
because people started using it behind
the scenes at id software
we were using cloud
going back to about
2009
we were baking mega textures in
aws
gpu early jeep you know kind of rough
gpu clouds
so
cloud became an early foundational tech
mobile became an ubiquitous everyone's
got one
blockchain still needs to kind of find
its pacing and find its path
and that's going to determine what
people think of it
so
i'll try to keep this going quickly
because i know i'm going through a lot
here
and i'm a little bit behind schedule so
zip through these the ico phase the
simplest thing to say about the ico
phase is that there's a point especially
here in san francisco where everyone was
talking icos
they
took over from from vr they became the
new big thing
everyone went into them everyone was
doing them
everyone started to love them or hate
them and there was no and they were
polarizing and then they all started to
crash
and
um
coming out of them
there were a lot of people who lost a
lot of money in them and it failed and
it failed really fast
um
so
um
i'll just leave it at that um
everyone has different feelings on them
but some of those icos that succeeded
uh that did not fail that continued
they still they went into the current
nft phase um so it's important to keep
that in context because a bunch of the
negative feeling around ico sorry around
nfts comes from memory of the icos that
were really just a few years ago and
that affected the development community
i would say more than anything else
so um
how has blockchain interacted with games
most coherently not only but most
coherently it is now this nft phase
where
you've got a bunch of folks going
from very different perspectives going
why don't gamers understand nfts
and it's because it's a bubble it's
too quick too soon um
it's
got people piling in that are not the
technologists
um
it's taking a thing where
even this notion of nfts has been around
for about 10 years and there have been
nft growth before that but it has not
gone into
effectively
this range of
fine arts and
um
and
pop culture arts
and a little bit of affecting
the hollywood range of kind of the
passive arts of film tv music and
animation and then coming over into
games and games is where
it has been
most negatively received
and i think in some ways it's because
people are still sore about icos but
also
the people going into it who have a
financial background or financial stake
are coming into a thing
thinking that it's the easiest thing for
nfts to go into
when games are going but we already kind
of do
95 of this we don't have a thing up on a
blockchain but all of these concepts
came out of us
and now you're pushing them back to us
with a twist telling us to do these
things
that we already kind of do
but now we have to do them while
somebody
is trying to make a fast buck on them
and the financial aspect
is the trickiest because we are
concerned about our consumers
and
this is what gamers see
this is a hilarious
bit from the most recent south park but
this is what gamers see
gamers are terrified right now
because they believe they're being set
up to be exploited
i mean i've literally seen you're trying
to turn us all into whales and then you
want to carve us up
there's this feeling that in this bubble
yeah it's a bit of the dot-com bubble
but there's this feeling of you're
trying to set us up to gut us
and it's an it's an existential fear
and the market is not helping
and so coming out of that
it's trying to get away from that
and go to something more positive
that is not exploitation
so how can
blockchain interact with games
mostly i would say it's repeat the path
of cloud
but also look at at the practicalities
of mobile because
the reality is that
cloud went in and brought in useful
things
and
showed that they're useful
and got adopted just behind the scenes
we all started using cloud first just in
our development processes and then to
roll stuff out
and
have it used more widely and to reach
more folks and go hey this is actually
better than bare metal
we've got to run a thing online and
we'll spin up
this cloud instance and it will sit
there and it's and cloud enabled us to
go to
better platforms and to go cross-device
and so that's the thing to keep in mind
is is that cloud has been adopted
because we just kind of went well we
kind of have to use it because it just
does these things that we need
and it's showing that there is stuff
that you need and then going
you know and it started with like oh i
can dump my mega textures onto
uh on onto the aws cloud and instead of
having my my machine churning for four
hours i'll get something back from aws
in 45 minutes
that to us at it was magic
i mean we knew exactly what it was doing
we'd set it up but we're like this is
perfect it's not tying up my machine i
just have to go into this um into this
custom web browser and just look at how
my thing is baking
um and we're like that's that's gold
you make developers lives easier and
they love you for it because they're
like hey
aws is just doing my thing and my
machine isn't locked up that's great
then microsoft came around
and and
the rise of azure started to fold into
this notion of xbox and
all of these useful and interesting
features and services that they were
trying to find ways to get connected
into and demonstrate in microsoft game
studios products and xbox or going oh i
could actually use that
that bit of machine learning that
machine translation i could use these
things
so
it's taking lessons from that
and so how is blockchain interacting
with games now um
game publishers and developers that are
in the traditional space are getting
burned by nfts for the most part not
everybody
but and some are just being very careful
about language
but
there are a lot of high profile projects
that or or developers or publishers that
are talking about things
and the public reaction is so negative
that they are about facing things that
they might have been planning for months
or more for a year you know let's say a
year or so they are changing in 24 hours
meanwhile and and it's happening because
they have revenue they have products
they have road maps
and
blockchain for the most part is an
ancillary thing and nfts were a cherry
on top but they're not going we're going
to make all of our money from that
startups on the other hand
oftentimes are being
driven entirely by
investors
and they
um
and a lot of these blockchains uh let's
say nft startups
i think is is really what we should call
many of them at this point or nft game
startups
a lot of them
do not have as their core staffing
traditional folks from the pc console
space
even a lot of them don't have mobile
they have some mobile developers they
have web developers social media
developers
it's
new folks coming in and that's okay
but they are over promising and under
delivering and they're selling a lot of
nfts and they're doing it with no
understanding of what is needed to
actually make anything
and so there's a certain amount of
i hope they don't screw up and i hope
they don't make us look bad and how much
of their stuff is going to disappear and
i honestly expect half of the nft game
projects to
to basically close up shop within the
next year to two years regard like it's
not about money yeah they got some money
and usually they don't have enough
but
in the game industry we've had lots and
lots of projects that had enough money
spent it the wrong way built their own
things built multiple times over threw
away things
it's never about the money and that's
the thing that people who are pushing
nfts need to understand
it's about the intersection of art and
technology to make something that you
can't plan
and that you can only iterate to achieve
when you are trying to make games when
you're trying to make vr virtual worlds
anything in that space
you can
guess
and how much experience and how much
judgment
is what gets you there
but you can never put together a rock
solid plan and you can never write a
white paper
ever
so
how does the game industry view nfts i'm
not going to read all these i'm just
going to kind of call them out you can
dive into these i'll make my deck
available a lot of these are in the news
but i'll just start with
tim's quote which i love for
being um
we are touching we aren't touching nfts
as as the whole field is currently
tangled up with an intractable mix of
scams interesting decentralized tech
foundation and scams now he changed this
but he changed it despite his competitor
valve's steam
he's not changing his core revenue
but he's making space within egs for a
thing
because he knows that steam isn't and
he's and they're still trying to figure
out what the hell they're actually going
to do with it and they don't know
um but everyone's guessing
so
why does the game industry care about
about scams
or about bad behavior in nfts that are
reflected on blockchain and crypto
because
video games
as a thing that's been around since the
60s
that
started to really gain traction in the
70s and has been going for a good long
while now effectively
six you know depending on how you want
to count either five or six decades we
are still a new medium compared to
tv animation
music
film
and
we still have legislators especially in
the eu the us the uk
who think of
games as being for children
and because of that
gambling laws are very real
legislation around
child endangerment
data privacy in general child data
privacy are very real
and what we know is that
we
the video game or the game industry
can get hit
by
legislation when parents go to
legislators and go
won't somebody please think of the
children
and it doesn't matter that most the
people playing are now adults
it just matters if children have access
to your thing
and they spend their parents money and
the parents complain
that is a cross that we the game
industry have to bear and that anyone
coming in has to bear with us
so
um
there's a platform response which is
that everyone's basically trying to fade
into the background and go yeah we're
not really ready to deal with this thing
so
nintendo microsoft sony apple google
steam epic also a bit of like 10 cent
and samsung all these folks that have
platforms
they are one concerned about blockchain
circumventing payment processing because
that is where they get their cut they
take 30 the developer publisher mix
takes 70 percent
so they are concerned
they will only consistently allow the
stuff on when they figure out how to get
their let's say 20 to 30 percent maybe
it is by having their own blockchains
maybe it is by banning blockchains maybe
it is by participating
and having their own systems with their
own nodes there's any number of
solutions but they don't know fully yet
and most of them are
doing different bits of kind of
censoring and soft bands and pulling
things and being very quiet about it
because everyone's still trying to
figure out this thing that they don't
quite know if they want to live with
so
here again i won't go into all these
we're just going to zip through these
but
ea is like yeah we're going to no we're
not going to sega is like yeah we're
kind of going to but unless it seems
like money making and then we're not
going to take two is like yeah we're
kind of already doing all this just not
on the blockchain but but we have
everything that you have already and we
have it in gta
ubisoft is like yeah we got this thing
oh nobody loves it
team 17 is like oh we're doing a thing
24 hours later we're not
um
the the stalker folks at gsc oh we're
doing a thing actually we're not
uh square enix we're doing something
we're using it we're not going to say
anything about how but we've kind of got
a thing um konami is basically going
yeah so
we're going to sell some stuff oh we
made you know 140 000
great
it doesn't really affect we're probably
going to do more it doesn't affect our
bottom line and epic going yeah we're
really not going to use it definitely
not going to use it in fortnite oh steen
just said they're definitely not going
to use it we're going to use it but
we're not going to say how we don't
actually host any games we're going to
review everything but we're not really
going to say what we're going to do but
it's going to be kind of there
so it's this really confusing mess of
things
and how was this different from mobile
mobile went in
and
the devices grew it was driven by the
devices
and
nobody just said hey i'm putting up a
medium blog or a white paper and we're
doing this thing no they just went out
and sold
because
the devices grew and the population grew
and
you saw this step like
people talk about play to earn play to
earn is [ __ ]
i'm sorry but you can't just go hey
we're talking about a thing we've
mentioned it a handful of times on
facebook linkedin therefore it exists
free to play
they just went out and did it and then
you went okay they're about three
variations on free free to play and i
can see like the appointment dynamics
are here
the uh consumable stuff is here the
adorable stuff is here they're finding
this mix but a they're taking stuff that
was kind of already in um facebook and
web gaming and b
they're putting it out and i can
go on to phones and i can find 10 15 20
examples immediately and they're making
money
it's real when you're making money off
of it not when you're talking about it
talk is cheap and we all do it and i'm
doing it right now but people go out in
mobile
and from 2012 to 2021 they took over a
chunk of the game industry by expanding
it and bringing new people in they
didn't initially try to cannibalize they
just went and said we're bringing all
these other folks in so that's
incredibly important
so with that
here's a really quick grounding and i
won't go into the specifics of these but
just
this is a scale effectively
triple i to single a to double a to
triple a to quadruple a and then you got
this blockchain thing over here that's
kind of still almost
being funded at least initially like oh
yeah we raised a bunch of nfts now we
can grow but the initial funding
is kind of the scale of like building an
expensive website
not
you know an enterprise website but like
a
expensive commercial website
where it's smaller than building a
mobile game and that's crazy
especially because people are looking at
it and going oh this is going to be
amazing and you're seeing a bunch of
concept art and some pre-rendered videos
and people are raising a ton of money on
nothing
and so on the one hand kudos to raising
money but on the other hand
do they know what they're doing
because
those six guys in the middle
that's my old boss on the left john
carmack
with kevin cloud
adrian carmack tom hall john romero and
jay wilbur six of those guys built
wolfenstein
and they knew what they were doing
because they built the commander keem
games uh
five or six of those before them and
they went on after wolfenstein to doom
they grew steadily and they grew along
the scale
and
the recent reboot of doom
that kevin cloud and john carmack were
still on
that was in that aaa phase
and then you know and the next
one will be in the quadruple a
they scaled all through this and they
understood it
games understand this range of
experiences and everything is tied to
money and time and people as you get
through it
so
what is game development i'm not going
to go into all this but basically just
to say
it's this range of specializations art
and animation design programming and
engineering audio production and then
behind the scenes publishing which
partially mirrors production
um
all of these things are needed back in
the day we just wore lots of hats but we
did pretty much all this still back then
with fewer people you get to more people
and bigger teams and there's more
specialization
but this core notion of
these
art and animation design programming and
engineering audio production these are
consistent everything that we make needs
this
and so you've got folks going in with
nfts going we've got some concept art
we've got some economy design we've got
a little bit of community management and
we're putting together a road map great
we can go write a white paper and we can
put up a web page and we can and we can
raise money and people in the game
industry are going no you need to
[ __ ] make something
like get something running like if
you're going to raise money show us that
you have a thing in motion or at least
have um at least have a production plan
that looks realistic and have a
deck you know maybe you don't have a gdd
but like have a pitch deck that shows
all the pieces of your thing and how it
fits together
um
white paper
and like that that's where the game
industry is struggling to understand
the
notions that nfts are trying to bring in
because they look like nonsense and
we're basically going you don't have a
plan and you're not going to be able to
make a thing and your thing is going to
fall apart and you're going to burn
everyone who goes in on it
because you don't understand what you're
making
and that's scary because those of us in
the game industry are in it mostly
because we love it
there are more and better things to do
if you want to make money faster than
make games yes it is the biggest
industry in the world
but game makers traditionally are not
the wealthiest people in the world
we do this because we love it
and we understand what we're making and
we share it and we'll talk about it but
we want people to know what they're
doing because
everyone who's in it has battle scars
everyone's been in the trenches everyone
has lost sleep and and been in crunch
because of the craziness that is the
unpredictability of making games
game development is hard um i won't
go into all this but there is this
notion
everyone in games know this knows this
it comes out of traditional engineering
but we took it on
it's you get 90 of the way through
you finally know what you have you're
deep in the middle of the thing
and then you get you then you start up
the other 90
and the remaining 10
is going to take another 90 percent of
time and i think
um
and and i i can remember both john
carmack and tim sweeney individually
saying this directly um taking it out of
engineering and then george brassard
going oh yeah like and george was
literally you know his
um
the founder of 3d realms going back to
the duke nukem days and he was literally
literally replying to tim swinney and
like you forgot the other not the middle
90 percent um and then i think there's
another person who's like oh and then
there's there's another 90 in polishing
there's this notion that like it's it's
never done and it's always complex and
it always takes more work than you think
it will and that actually gets to my
quote at the end um
which i had said a while back which is
that you can't make a great game the
first time out no matter who you are you
make it
you make a
good game with a great team
figure out who you have what your
pipelining is what your process is and
then you're going to make a great game
when you have a team that has previously
made a good game together
because you have to recognize how many
90 you have
sitting in front of you
so online games are doubly hard um
remember that this is this is being uh
shared out to everyone afterwards you
can go through this
ralph coster um
fantastic developer and and a great
human being raf was the lead designer
for ultima online um he was also the
director for star wars galaxies he's
been involved at this point i think in
like five or six
large mmos
at one point he went
around the
california texas mmo community and he
started collecting rules um his his
rules of online world design if
something you know high ropes loophole
if something can be abused it will be um
there are a ton of these we're running
out of time i won't go through all of
them but what i want to stress is that
there's this collective understanding of
30 years of online
game design
that it is harder more complex more
curious
and more mercurial than anyone realizes
until they dive into it so anytime
someone new is coming in we go
you're about to get screwed we'll help
you out as much as we can we'll show you
a bunch of stuff but it's going to hurt
and it does
and so there are a ton of these
uh these rules players have higher
expectations of the virtual world than
the real one um
the psychological disinhibition of if
you have anonymity people will be jerks
the mass market problems of your
administrative problems will increase
exponentially and not linearly the
notion that violence either
direct or social
psychological
will be done if you allow people to
interact in the world no matter what
happens
we do not as an industry believe that
you can just let people go into a utopia
and they will treat each other well and
they will self-police and they can just
set up a bunch of daos and run
everything
we know
from historical fact
that some portion of that that audience
will always destabilize the rest
and that the people who are paying
expect a good experience
you have to police you have to moderate
you have to curate you have to deal with
hackers you have to
help people
push and shape into a right thing
and there can be a hybrid between
even in a social order between
centralization and decentralization but
you cannot have pure decentralization
because it is chaos
in games
so
there's an identity crisis um
do you want to let people
have a speculative penny stock a unit of
currency
a functional utility
utilitarian tool
you can you know
the typical triangle of good fast and
cheap you can never have all three
what we see here is that you can have
two of these kinda you can have one of
these really well
you can try to do three and you'll tear
yourself apart
what does that mean
that we don't really know what we're
going into with blockchain gaming
um people hold up axey infinity
axiomfinity is an outlier and it's not
really a game it's a gamified economy
and it is the equivalent of pokemon go
where
for a few years people said
hey this is just the beginning of the
the tip of the iceberg of all these
mobile ar games and then none of the
other ones ever got
um an audience
and mobile ar
as an overall industry trend crashed
there's still mobile ar technology and
there's still people messing around and
it's going more local
but
there is no field of mobile ar gaming
uh there is no revenue other than one
thing axi infinity is currently that
you cannot prove an industry through one
thing
so what do we have right now
we have nft
um land sales
which are
basically so trying to sell the the
brooklyn bridge or trying to sell people
that they own a star
it's not that it can't become something
but
in the view of the game industry
if you haven't made a thing before if
you don't know what you're making
you tell a bunch of people
in the current market you can sell that
and they will buy that but you are
selling hot air
and traditionally that is seen as
criminal
um
the person who tried to sell the
brooklyn bridge was was put in jail
you cannot sell a thing that is either
in the public common or
that is uh effectively
um
that doesn't exist
upland right now is trying to sell stuff
that are effectively in the pub in the
public comment
i'm hoping that they get knocked down
because they should not be able to sell
people's addresses
that maps ar notion of connecting the
address is great but speculating on that
worries me
um
selling things that don't exist
is a lot of what the
games in nft is doing right now because
the people who are promising them
have no idea the pain that they're going
to have
in adhering to the contract
for the sale that they made before
they've actually made anything
virtual item sales and avatar sales are
the other part
and those are fraught with disaster
because
they run massive risks of changing the
balance of the game and forcing you to
re-change it
and the biggest example that i can bring
up is blizzard and diablo 3.
they set up the real money auction house
and that real money auction house
broke diablo 3 and they had to close it
down despite the fact that it was the
most successful thing that they had ever
put out
it was causing new people
to come in less and it was causing
people to stop playing and to just
purchase
and they basically sat down and looked
at it and said
this kills our game play this kills our
game
do we only want the auction house and
they said no and they shut it down
the point is
it's really hard to balance a game in an
an economy together and this gets to my
question and i'm just about done here so
we'll get wrapped up and i know we're
we're on time or well we're
cresting at that time
is that do you want to make a game or do
you want to make an economy
anyone going into nft gaming is going to
have to ask this question because you
cannot have your eight your cake and eat
it too
and connected in with that is that play
to earn and
what i call paid exploit pte
is an unproven guess
it's a thing that we don't actually know
it's a thing that has not yet been
defined it has to be defined in practice
and not in white papers
and what we see right now
is that
you can't have your cake and eat it too
and people are trying to do that and
they don't know what they're going to
come up against because you cannot
coherently design play
and work and have them have equal value
they will push at each other and one
will win and you have to prioritize
in games when we're doing game
development you always have to
prioritize your features your service
your design your plans your content
you have to prioritize play and work
also
do you want an economy first or do you
want a game first a game is about play
and leisure activity
a work product is about
productivity and knowing that you did
something consistently and you cannot
have the thumb on the scale on the one
hand and have balance and curation on
the other
so what can blockchain
advocates do slow down let the bubble
burst
find experiments
learn and listen
understand the space
help to build consortiums help to grow
and figure out standards
and fight scams
because there's a lot of work that needs
to be done
just pointing out the hardest thing in
games is raising money at the start
game developers do want help with this
every new person coming into games wants
to figure this out
but
it has to be done
without locking the people into a design
that is not yet done
that's the problem with nfts right now
is they're locking they're pre-selling
and locking in a design where the people
who are who are selling it do not know
the design even even if they're
experienced developers like peter mall
and his group who sold i think it was
54 million in in in virtual land and and
peter's fantastic and he's a veteran
with more experience than i do and if
you sit down and talk to him honestly
he's probably excited and terrified
because he has a lot of people who've
been sold a lot of stuff and they have
to figure out what the hell their game
is
because you never actually know until
you're making the game
so what are the issues i'm not going to
go into all these but my god they're
complex i could do a lecture just on
these and i'm actually going to be doing
a panel discussion on all of these at
the game developers conference next
month
there are a lot of problems every
problem can be solved
but the issue is
there are now more problems than
solutions
and the people who are coming in
are focused on making money and not
solving and so
talking to your group here
figuring out how to work with enterprise
figuring out how to
provide
experiments
to evolving ideas to solutions
because we want to make sure
that we actually solve these because the
game industry always takes in new
technology
but we never guarantee that it's going
to be a hit in the first year and it
takes time to figure things out and
there's a lot of work to be done
i had a whole thing on interoperability
that i'm mostly going to bypass
it's here in my notes
i will just say that
interoperab easy interoperability is a
myth
and without going into all the
complexity of a few slides i'll just say
take a socket wrench
jam it in a chocolate cake
that's interoperability in games
because
every group makes their game
individually they use middleware engines
in different ways lots of folks still
build custom engines most of the games
that make money do not use unreal or
unity and probably never will
every
major developer
frankly
every publisher has multiple custom
engines everybody rolls their own
call of duty has three different custom
engines for the three different groups
that make sure that call of duty comes
out every year
they cannot be interoperable just within
call of duty across years
a socket wrench
has measurements it's used for
automotive repair it is an artificial
human construction a cake is also an
artificial human construction a socket
wrench is not tasty
a cake is not great for automotive
repair
they are two things built
by humans for different things
trying to take assets from one game to
another is the socket wrench and the
chocolate cake and until people realize
this and stop acting like it's easy we
can't actually make file format
standards that can allow us
to eventually do it in the future
because we could have a thing where we
can go the socket wrench is part of this
class and the cake is part of the
consumables class and this tool class
and consumable we can do all that and
that's going to take 10 to 20 years to
it's going to take 10 years to do it and
another 10 years to get people on board
it's absolutely doable if we want to get
towards a metaverse and shared stuff it
can happen
but it does not happen easily and it's
really not happening now
so there's a whole lot of of
what can and cannot be done with
interoperability
um
but i'm just going to come back to
the blockchain trilemma
you guys already understand this from
the perspective of
security scalability decentralization
you can't have all of these perfectly
in that same fashion
going into games specifically there is a
blockchain trilemma in games of
a particular thing that you bring in
cannot be a penny stock a currency and a
utilitarian tool
right now
just about every group going in is doing
that it needs to be it's like pick one
first make one
[Music]
your primary choice
what's the secondary let the third one
fall away
everything coming in has to choose that
because
games are about hard choices
so i i know i've gone a little bit over
thank you guys for being um
for for being